[Music]  that is London  sixty minutes is all it took to bring  humanity to the very brink of extinction  mankind mobilized a new age arose the  age the great predator city's survival  of the fastest  hey watch out Valentine  this is for my mother  Oh ask him what you murdered my mother  I'm sorry you had to head  as to Shawn she won't stop until I'm  dead unless you kill her first I want  them found  I've been looking for you for a long  time your mother she said she had found  something dangerous she was afraid of  Valentine of what he might do man who  controls this controls the world she  said that you could stop him his weapon  can wipe out the largest city in the  blink of an eye  not if we shut it down  nothing can stand in the face of this we  have to stop London before it destroys  us  I'm sure you want to do this once we go  in there's no going back  I have to  [Music]  [Music]